من كيف اعلن الامين العام للناتو مره اخرى
ان اوكرانيا قريبه من الانضمام للحلف
مؤكدا تقدمها في الهجوم
المضاد اوكرانيا حاليا اقرب الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي من اي وقت مضى اليوم تتقدم قواتكم
انها تواجه قتالا شرسا لكنها تتقدم
ميدانيا بشكل
تدريجي التقى ستوت البر بالرئيس الاوكراني
في زياره مفاجئه الى ص الاوكرانيه اتنم
زسك الفرصه ليطلب من الحلف المزيد من
الاسلحه بهدف التصدي للهجمات الروسيه على
البنى التحتيه للطاقه المرتقب هذا
الشتاء لقد ناقشنا امكانيه توفير ما
نحتاجه من انظمه الدفاع الجوي من قبل
الدول
الاعضاء ووافق الامين العام على بذل
الجهود اللازمه لمساعدتنا ودعمنا وتعبئه
الدول الاعضاء في
الحلف
يوم الخميس كانت العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
تعج بالضيوف ا زار وزير الدفاع البريطاني
والفرنسي المدينه لبحث تقديم المزيد من
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا وعدت باريس
بمواصله دعمها
لكيف نعلم ان هذه الحرب ستستمر مصداقيتنا
تعتمد عليها منذ البدايه تم تسليم كل ما
وعدنا به وسنستمر على هذا النحو وسنظل
ملتزمين بمساعده اوكرانيا تاتي هذه
الزياره قبيل انعقاد منتدى الصناعات
الدفاعيه الاول في كياف بحضور اكثر من 160
شركه دفاع و26
دوله